hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to princess nom nom now this
game i found on heo that apparently
works like the slime rancher game but
only in that aspect that you got to feed
this thing until it explodes i'm not all
represent sure about that just like i'm
not honor of censure about anything in
life i don't want to make any
declarations about things that i do not
know
cuz i don't want to seem like I know
more than I do which isn't really a risk
knowing myself but anyway you just you
just popped out a baby out of your belly
button you just popped out a baby out of
your belly button what are you doing oh
nice
again yes you you popped out a baby out
of your belly button that's a little
disturbing okay I am very confused see I
go into these games I don't know what
the [ __ ] is happening you know what
apparently these little bastards go get
food to feed princess nom nom princess
nom nom then shoots out another baby
everything's gonna be okay run forest
run reduce the time needed to get food
from the forest upgrade some of the food
looted from the forest whoa in a weird
way this is like a bee colony I suppose
so somehow with some funkalicious music
go feed princess there's some there's
some like meta story to this game that
you just gotta really think about in
terms of like the logistics of this this
horrible alien landed on earth and just
start spitting out babies and playing
happy-go-lucky music and then all of a
sudden eco-terrorism abound the whole
forest is devastated because I can see
the exponential growth of this equation
and it doesn't end well for all humanity
well at all but [ __ ] it you know what
all hail princess nom nom let's go get
her all the food that she requires so
that we can destroy the world
Oh God in the voices when they go that's
not a happy voice like I don't know what
this button does but I'm afraid for it
because something about this game just
makes me fearful for all of humanity
Oh Lake what are you gonna do what are
you gonna
oh you're now destroying the oceans and
our aquatic habitats oh boy
well better make more babies we need
more food I probably shouldn't be you
know open this this is bad for everybody
in fall but it's cute so nobody's I can
get an upgrade or I can open a farm I
guess I would be more responsible unless
that farm has livestock and it's just
gonna end up with more you okay princess
nom nom you all right there sweetie
oh go oh boy oh and they're a little
randomly generated oh they have
different Tufts of hair they're cute
[Music]
well this music reminds me of whoo how
many people out there played Super Mario
legend of the seven star Super Mario RPG
legend of the Seven Stars which is by
far my favorite RPG I've ever played
it's one of the best and it was on the
Super Nintendo and it was absolutely
incredible game I love that game so much
but the music of it kind of reminds me
of that game and I don't know why all
right you know what I'm gonna stop
bitching and moaning about the potential
catastrophic effects of whatever the
hell is going on over here
come on that's gonna you know let
bygones be bygones you know whatever the
world's gonna be destroyed but who cares
alas what else can you do let's open a
farm oh there is livestock oh there is
livestock are we just gonna feed raw
pigs into this thing because that does
not seem good go back oh you went to a
wheat farm and you pulled a t-bone steak
all right let's upgrade ok reforestation
ok radical fishing all right all right
let's open up this pig farm I can't I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna see what I owe
the one with the devil horns goes over
there ok or what are you gonna bring
back I don't know where you're going I
don't know what you're doing did you pay
for that did you pay for that it was a
cupcake made by probably human hands did
you pay for that I'm gonna assume you
stole it at best and that's the best
option here oh I think princess nom nom
is getting bigger which I think it's a
bad thing
all right can we upgrade ridiculous
fishing see reduce new areas price but
I'm already almost at the top of the
list
now whatever that's as scary it's like
Teletubby levels of scary of those
voices there's a payoff reward for this
ok we got the last one here let's go for
it
go get it go to get a devil Warren man
Oh Golden Apple oh that's that's good I
did I'm assuming you stole that from the
gods on Mount Olympus which also
represents something bad that you
probably shouldn't do but if this thing
can even steal
and or barter from the gods and we are
in bigger trouble than I thought
it's weird I I don't actively see a
point to all of this but I'm weirdly
compelled to keep going food food looted
from the village food looted o speed of
all okay alright let's do that pop a
pill I don't know what pill you're
popping probably crack if crack comes in
pill form you know a pill of crack
I know drugs I shouldn't know drugs
that's not a good thing to claim oh my
god the forest crew is just looking in I
don't know 25% faster they seem way
faster than they used to be like my
goodness I can't keep up this food
alright okay increase food gains oh
you're the crown I don't know how that
works do you ration it or you just eat
it faster do you chew your food Princess
nom nom I have so many questions
princess nom nom I feel like we've come
a long way from doing Shahla
I feel like you could be open at all
this to be about what the [ __ ] we're
doing some day your minions are gonna
wonder why they're doing the things that
they are doing or baby dot maybe they're
happier just being buoyed list begins
okay anyway good day to you right time
to upgrade everything else her I don't
do that was a useless upgrade in the
Navy alright YMCA okay alright um Peter
noosed we did more babies princess boob
Fritz's dip dip we did more babies
princess dip dip we need a lot more
babies oh boy empress of numb hop hoping
hoping discount not popping hoping
origin of all nom transcend your nom
existence become the nom itself I want
that I'm gonna take this one nokey dokey
then we need more Dobbs
you and your crowd is so big mama nom
nom you're so big
look at their faces they're the face all
right maybe we should transcend all nom
all right oh [ __ ] oh come on I don't
want to click you well what good did
that do me what good does that do me
this is the upgrade available now oh
maybe I needed to get all the other
upgrades before I can get that one god
damn it I gotta do it again I gotta do
it oh [ __ ] again [ __ ] well here we go
again
down this insane path of feeding
princess nom nom which is definitely a
good use of my time maybe I can do it
faster now now that I know what I'm
doing alright now I guess we gotta start
pumping out the other one we need to
maximize production we don't have enough
you guys need to work harder y'all suck
alright we're gonna get that one go get
that one we're gonna get that one okay
we're gonna get the Opus Dei
then we're gonna good dude yeah but
we're not ready to do that just yeah we
need more babies it's a weird thing to
say out loud we need a lot more babies
princess nom nom pump-out babies I don't
know how you're making them by yourself
but you know what I actually don't want
to know I'm gonna take that back I'm
perfectly content with not knowing how
you're making all these baby blue I
yourself whoa look at the [ __ ] cakes
on you holy [ __ ] look at you Manny's got
to go out upgrade absolutely
everything it's I actually realize now
that this is gonna take a good long
while what's it gotta be like for one of
these little bastards to be born into
the world just suddenly thrust into get
mother some food get Bob from booze
oh my god I'm realizing the full
ramifications of the task that I have
set upon me it is a bunch of [ __ ]
yeah we're over a hundred thousand foods
I think I should celebrate but we're not
even near to our goal because we got to
spawn two more of these bad boys and
upgrade the other one two more times and
that is even if this is gonna lead to
some secret secret dark secret I don't
know almost there
might as well pop out the extra baby
okay here we go
I'm gonna upgrade the last one it better
give me another upgrade oh and no doing
this to myself what could you possibly
be I have no goddamn idea but either way
I don't know I guess I'm at the end of
my rope here
I've been doing this for [ __ ] an hour
then why was the point what did it get
me gonna be nothing gonna be a whole lot
of nothing oh no so I guess that is that
that's princess nom nom we will never
know we'll never know we'll never know
why who've ever know what well they're
nowhere we'll never know when
it's just that's that's just it so that
is the end of princess nom nom here's
one more baby for the road and still no
final upgrades so if you guys have the
patience for it let me know how to get
it maybe it's a secret easter egg that
you got to click around on one of these
rocks or something I don't know but that
is all that I might do for this one so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I'll put a link down the description
below for you to guys to bash your head
against a wall on princess nom noms
belly so thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]